let's make some s'mores can we smart up
smart up okay we've got a whole
selection here well I refuse to eat one
on principle but you guys go ahead I
think it's uh you're doubling down I
don't think you really think it's the
worst I do but how can I can you give me
again what I always said was it's way
overrated it's not as good as it's
cracked up to be now Sony because I
wanna I wanna give this a full shot how
much do I roast this it's already too
much it's already too much that was too
much you don't want her in the fire you
wanna you wanna turn her so that she
gets slowly roasted these are gender to
the point where she all like falls off
of your skewer that means you like what
the what is that oh my God oh my God I'm
trying to get it off so I can start
again so bad look I'm now just feeding
my marshmallow off of yours yeah it you
got to be really gentle Shona aren't I
doing it the right way I'm warming the
marshmallow awesome you got it I know
the moment it starts to get like that
you have to blow it out I
Scorch but I'm seeing some people
scorching they're like I'm done and it's
not the right way to do it you have to
actually melt the marshmallow which
takes some time and patience and I think
that's also part of the reason why you
don't make good s'mores it's a real
tough balance is it though sorry
this is not a hard thing to do okay what
do we talk about are we just posting
some hand me some Graham cracks yeah you
know you're trying to be so hard to be
casual that it's excruciating you keep
shortening words that can't be shortened
take a Jamie a Hersh from a Graham crack
yeah I gotta get them harsh for your
Graham crack thanks you can put it on
the old skew thanks cone uh this is
living yep doesn't get better than this
listening to people make a shitty
dessert
is what podcasting was meant for
eat your heart out Mark Maron this is
what it's all really been about from the
beginning are you listening Peabody oh
Peabody how do you get this whole thing
in your mouth though Sona oh first of
all right
if you guys are using all right you know
those are just soft you want smaller
ones how do you get this whole thing in
your mouth
cut to Mr Furley or better yet Norman
Fell listening outside the door yeah
I've always wanted there to be a Threes
Company Jack and Chrissy are behind a
door Mr Roper's listening and he's
saying things like push it harder push
it harder no no it's not fitting here
rub it and then it will get harder and
then Mr Mr Roper's getting upset and you
cut inside and they really are [ __ ]
and really graphic it's just incredibly
graphic and you just you cut to whatever
Don Knotts freaking out or whatever
wouldn't that be great yeah if it is Mr
Robert he actually comes in he's like oh
I actually apologize yeah sorry I'm
sorry I assumed that you were putting a
shower head on
because I know there was an episode
where they're putting a shower you know
what I want to do here's what I want to
do or could someone do this for me
there's a Three's Company episode where
I do think it's Don Knotts as Mr Furley
is listening I think Jack and Chrissy
are behind the door the door is shut
yeah and they're in the bathroom and I
think they are just trying to put a
shower head on it's like push harder I'm
trying you're making this stuff here you
get on top and done not just making all
those faces yeah if someone just cut
incredibly hardcore pornography into
that I think that would be absolutely
hilarious I agree could someone do that
out there because I don't have time in
my backyard no no no no just listening
in this okay that's what's great about
America is you tell someone can you just
do a oh look at this oh Sona that's what
a appetizing dessert it looks like a
burned vertebrae
the vertebrae of a fire victim I gotta
say this is absolute horseshit because
the skin of the cooked marshmallow has
exited the innards and it's just like a
mess that you can't you can't even eat
it too big this is the problem this
marshmallow let's take one of your thigh
bones I will but I also just want to
point out look at that perfect melt yeah
but that's a disaster that looks
terrible now what are you are you
actually gonna you're just pretending to
like this you don't like that I can't
eat it they're impossible to eat it's
like when you get a cheeseburger at a
restaurant it comes in it's like 18
inches high it's really good you guys I
can't I don't understand you two I don't
I'm so happy it just makes me angry to
even see you eat it